When working a sew-as-you-go method
of joining seams,
it can be difficult to locate which strand
to pick up, especially when working
on the standard gauge machine.
Creating a neat seam can be a challenge.
We've used this technique to knit socks
in a flatbed knitting machine
sew-as-you-go eliminates sewing
up the side seams by hand.
Here's one method. If you loop a strong,
smooth, contrasting yarn along each row as
you knit, it's much easier
to identify the loops to pick up.
I'm using a crochet bedspread cotton,
but you could use any yarn
that will slide out easily.
I've tied one into the cotton through
the end of my double eye needle.
You could also use a darning needle.
On the carriage side,
drop the needle behind the working yarn
and loop the cotton over the working yarn.
Don't pull it tight.
You don't want to distort
the edge stitch of your knitting.
Knit over and back.
Pick up your needle from the front.
Drop the needle back behind the working
yarn and loop the cotton
over the working yarn.
Again, knit over and back.
Be consistent.
How you're picking up that needle and
putting it over behind the working yarn.
Keep repeating this up the entire
edge that's going to be joined.
The contrast color loops identify the
knots and the loops are clearly visible.
Use your transfer tool to pick up the loop
of your knitting and hang it
on the machine, doubling up
the edge stitch of your knitting.
If you pick up the cotton
at the same time, it won't hurt.
Just might be a little bit harder to get
that cotton out when you're all done.
Once the piece is done,
just pull out that crochet cotton.
Gently pull the seam to pop the stitches
in place, and you'll have a nice cabled
look that is secure
and tidy for your project.
It's also comfortable in socks.
Another idea is the bobby pin trick.
Similar to the previous method,
we'll isolate the loops that will be used
to seam the piece. On the carriage side,
carefully hang a bobby
pin on the working yarn.
Don't pull down.
You might also want to hold the yarn as
it's fed into the carriage so you don't
get a big loop on the edge of your
knitting because of the marker.
Carefully knit to the left.
Check to make sure that the pin isn't
sticking up, and then knit back.
Hang another bobby pin knit over.
Check to make sure it's not going to get
caught up in your carriage, and knit back.
Repeat this for the entire length
of the seam, identifying each one
of the loops from every other row.
When it's time to join this section,
pick up each loop by the pin
and hang it on the machine needle.
Knit over and back.
Keep repeating.
Pick up the loop.
Hang it on the machine again.
You're doubling up those edge stitches.
You're not adding any stitches
you're just doubling up seaming.
Carefully remove the pin each time.
You'll have a neat and tidy seam with no
guesswork about which strands to pick up
try both of these methods
and see which one you like.
They will improve your
sew-as-you-go seaming.